quand on associe russie et vaccination
on pense assez vite au spoutnik v le
vaccin russe qui est actuellement en
train d'être examinés par l' agence
européenne des médicaments
mais il n'est pas le seul deux autres
vaccins étaient approuvés par les
autorités russes dont les pies vague
corona développer ici à l'institut
vector de novossibirsk le centre d'état
de recherche en virologie et
biotechnologies vector crée du temps de
l'urss possède aujourd'hui un
laboratoire qui a donc mis au point un
vaccin efficace à 100% tout du moins
après les premières phases de test
bien sûr il est trop tôt pour parler de
protection à 100%
nous parlons d'une efficacité
immunologique à 100% dans la deuxième
phase des essais cliniques
nous avons sélectionné un groupe de
volontaires sains qui ont été isolés
pendant trois semaines de vaccination
notre hôpital
ils ont été vaccinés et ont tous répondu
à la vaccination avec une bonne réponse
immunitaire
il s'agit d'une activité immunologique
pas d'une protection nous en apprendront
davantage sur la protection d'ici l'été
au togo
c'est dans cette partie du laboratoire
que l'on élabore en quelque sorte la
base du vaccin dit nous s'il vous plaît
en quoi consiste cette étape nous sommes
dans la salle de fermentation c'est ici
que s'accumulent la biomasse de cellules
productrices de la protéine porteuse le
composant principal des vaccins campagne
bien par la suite des protéines
synthétique des peptides sont attachés à
cette protéine nptii des accumule donc
ici la biomasse cellulaire à partir de
laquelle l'un des principaux opposants
et du vaccin epibac corona est ensuite
extrait t va s'aimer et pegatron le
contrôle de la qualité des vaccins est
également une étape primordiale du
processus soit avant chaque lot faisait
l'objet d'essais précliniques et
inique et maintenant avant d'être mises
en circulation chaque lot passe par
trois étapes de contrôle
la première est celle du contrôle
obligatoire de chaque étape de
production dans le laboratoire
ensuite le vaccin vient tanoh au
département de contrôle biologique et
technologique
on vérifie si le produit est conforme à
toutes les exigences de la documentation
réglementaire
la prochaine étape importante et
qu'avant d'être mises en circulation
civile
le vaccin est soumis à un contrôle au
niveau d'une institution fédérale qui
vérifie le respect des exigences
établies lors de l'enregistrement du
médicament ainsi chaque lot de vaccins
subi un triple contrôle de sorte que
seul un vaccin de haute qualité soit mis
sur le marché avec épi vague corona la
russie dispose d'un deuxième vaccin
contre le coran la virus un vaccin
prometteur qui doit encore faire ses
preuves